hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play doorways
okay so it dropped me before I had
collected everything and before I
deactivated or activated some of these
torture machines and it kind of got me
for a second there because the professor
he spawned in a place he wasn't supposed
to spawn before so that kind of was
jarring but you didn't see that so it's
like it never happened
I just have to go through these again to
make sure that he never commits these
horrible crimes of whatever the hell
he's doing I have no idea he's just a
sick demented bastard that's what he is
get in there I know I can press I I'm
just too stupid to realize this I'm I'm
horrific ly stupid everybody who's
watching this and just terribly awfully
stupid go get more wood haha as a funny
joke cuz wood it means badass okay
anyway so well
alright enough dick jokes let's get out
of here
so I don't know if I've gotten
everything but I've clicked spam
basically everywhere I could in this
entire game forever and ever never never
never never never never never never
never never never
I don't know how many Evers I need on
that one but I've got a lot of Evers
just know that the thing no that's not
the thing is the thing doesn't look like
the thing is this the thing oh my god
that was actually the thing I didn't
think that thing was gonna be the thing
but it was a thing all right
so but that's bad that's a bad thing
because now I don't have my torch
anymore at least I have the answer to
all my oh it is dark in here it's dark
gray for a darkness okay can we go back
to the dick jokes I like that why is
this one light rum orange that's what I
want to know or yellow or whatever you
want to call it
that's the bad one that's the one that I
don't like personally if I had a choice
I would not pick that one I'm just
saying that right now okay last one I
only have one thing left so let's hope
this works
okay still I mean that as I was going
through all this again I know I've been
pressing I as I've been going through
this again I've been inundated by the
strange noises where does it go I don't
know where this got whoa there we go did
I get it wait no ah ha ha ha
oh why why that's what I want to know
why are you a sick demented bastard who
has no love for anyone but yourself what
was that that might have been a bar door
opening I think I remember there being a
door over where way no over here
it was a door over here yep Eldar Oh
give me the heebie-jeebies you ready
vidi-vidi Reeves you have a DVD is this
an elevator
why is there an elevator here what kind
of weird damn Barry it is all of this
well I guess Castle it could be an
abandoned castle that was there before
Oh No chapter one finished finished
finished want to know that I wanted
better than the line one what are you
dumb ah dollars oh wait a minute what
stay updated for the neck but I bought
chapter 1 to 4 you have to one fall oh
is this just like a demo well that's a
pretty long demo but I paid money for it
you know you know how that be that
started strange well I guess that's it
then nah huh huh
well this is disappointing finished
early here just plug it all of what
dodge yeah okay so since the ending of
that game even it's just a demo by the
way it's just a demo apparently I did
not know that going into it or else I
wouldn't have you know I've done in one
part I did not know but since that was
that I'm gonna do something totally
ridiculous which is a game that someone
sent to me that I don't know you got it
you got it you just kind of got to see
it so this one is called a world you
should not know and there are various
reasons why you should not know this
world dun dun duh duh
and da da dun dun dun I want to preface
this I am NOT a brony in any way not
that anything wrong with anything but
this is another my little pony
creepypasta game so I don't know I just
got in here and the reason I haven't
played it before is because I turned
left and I was like oh it's oh okay well
too late now let's get to playing now I
don't know if the objective I hear that
I don't know what the objective what is
that you're big
oh my god ah what the hell are you
good golly Miss Molly get out of here ah
okay yeah I don't know okey what up sex
it's right behind might is right behind
like okay wow I didn't expect something
it's freakishly hellish is that so
anyway what is this is this supposed to
be all that love and happiness that
you're pushing on everybody want any of
your love and happiness I mean I know
you did I know you just want to give me
a big hug no thank you
I'm okay being without that hug yeah
little Darth Vader action going on got a
little breathing problems you're a
little pretty heavy right down my neck
to my right I brought one of you hide up
here with more than one of you how's
that bout to be any sort of fair
well this is a nightmare into an of
itself
can he get me while I'm back here Kenny
Kenny gimme I'm a hidin I'm a hidey
hidey hole okay okay that was weird
I've only got one key and I want to quit
and go cry to my mommy go hide in the
corner in the corner baby corner
ah ba-bye they keep getting behind me by
Bobby
Oh is in front of me oh and one of those
in front of me behind me yeah quit
dropping plates over there you're a
horrible server waiter waitress I don't
know what gender you are I don't want to
find out I think I'll find out if you
catch me so I'm not gonna hum a never
get away you're ugly and I hate you I
don't know how to win
oh you sir oh you're so weird just died
god you're like some weird transformer
if someone threw a bunch of ponies into
a meat grinder and you fell out the ass
end of it okay that's horrific that is
the most horrifying I think I've seen in
any horror game ever ever ever ever ever
ever ever ever they keep getting about
I'm eight did I lose do not one
I don't wanna is there another way is
there another door I could take that
goes away from there let's see if I just
keep backing up how are that get me
well that get me come on uh I don't want
to go in there I don't want to go in
there I know now why this is the world I
should not know cuz this is I've reached
the back end of it okay so alright let's
go ahead Frank forget forget forget love
you what you got Oh see what you got oh
look it's a nightmare
oh just what I've always wanted okay
let's find the stupid keys you know I
can't even tell where the hell I'm going
half the time ah Jer ah okay I think
it's all one over here yeah
on I got one key I got one key so I
looping through the other places I have
no idea where the other keys are because
it didn't seem like there were any keys
over there well okay this is where all
my dreams go to die along with the rest
of me ah sneak attack thank you
I've got fair that's hardly that's not
fair
all right know what I'm not gonna win
this I can't I could tell right now I'm
not gonna win this so I'm done with that
hope you're all confused like I am oh
man this game was made on blender by the
way which is a 3d modeling software I
did not know that it could make games so
there you go the more you know more you
learn lest you want to play this so
anyway thank you all so much for your
watching for your watching thank you so
much for your eyeballs which are
watching the screen so thanks again and
as always I will see you next video
ah
thank you
I guess I could have guessed that one I
mean it's cheese pink
no they're not dead there seem to be the
spines are they mating in there